So let me summarize what
the steps that we've taken
are to do this
differential analysis.
So when you're trying to analyze
a continuous mass distribution,
the first step is to pick
some arbitrary mass element,
a small but finite
size mass element
somewhere in the middle
of the mass distribution.
You don't want to pick
one of the endpoints,
because the endpoints
are special.
You want to pick an arbitrary
point somewhere in the middle
and then pick a small mass
element at that point, so
a small but finite size.
Analyze the forces acting
on that mass element.
So write down Newton's second
law, the equation of motion,
for that mass element.
That will give you what the
forces are on that element.
Then go to the limit of an
infinitesimally small element.
That will give you a
differential equation.
You can then separate
the differential equation
and integrate both sides
to solve the differential
equation.
And then finally, you can
apply a boundary condition,
something you know about one
or the other of the endpoints.
And that will allow you to solve
for the function of interest
at any point along
your distribution.